Kylie Jenner says she's always been an  outsider let you feel like an outcast  from Sunday's life of Kylie premiere the  19 year old reality star reveals that  she's always felt like she didn't fit in  I have a soft spot for the outcast  because I was the outcast I guess in a  lot of ways growing up and I still feel  like an outcast in different ways now  cuz I'm can't relate to a lot of people  Kylie soft spot for the outcast makes  her even more excited to surprise her  fan Albert at his prom in Sacramento in  the clip the star face times with  Albert's mom and learns he was  devastated when no girl would be his  date to the dance  just seeing Albert's mom and the emotion  she has for her son I don't know it's  just not cool kids are mean these days  and it's it's not right to treat people  like that  [Music]